[Music]
foreign
preview a first look at what is on the
front page is time then to see what's
making the headlines where the columnist
and broadcaster Steve Richards and the
political commentator and former
conservative special advisor Sal
Michelle welcome to both of you with us
from now until just before midnight to
the front pages then let's start with
the eye which says the government is
bracing for a winter of discontent as
transport staff NHS workers teachers and
members of unions and a number of other
sectors all plan to go on strike
the express criticizes possible
government plans to delay the
introduction of a cost cap for social
care funding the financial times reports
that inflation in the US has fallen at a
faster rate than expected
the telegraph leads with a call from the
U.S to Ukraine to use the G20 to find a
route to peace in its war with Russia
the times has an interview with the
former Chancellor quasi quateng where he
says he tried to warn Liz truss that her
radical economic reforms would not work
The Daily Mail looks at the latest
Motorway chaos caused by just stop old
protesters and asks what is the point of
these police
well the guardian has an exclusive with
news that a hundred thousand children
are missing out on free School meals
after the eligibility criteria was
frozen
according to the Metro the comedian and
Britain's Got Talent Judge David
Williams has been forced to apologize
after archival off-air footage emerged
showing him making derogatory sexual
remarks about contestants and the star
has the story of a woman who had an
unfortunate run-in with a seagull
a psycho one anyway a reminder by
scanning the QR code you'll see on
screen through the program you can check
out the front pages but in the meantime
let's go to our guest straight away and
I'm afraid we don't start with cheer
kicking off Salma with the eye reading
that first paragraph goodness me a
hundred thousand civil servants vote to
join nurses train drivers postal workers
bus drivers London Underground staff bin
men midwives baggage handlers University
lecturers and are walking out with
teachers firefighters and 300 000 NHS
workers all balloting for strikes
goodness me what a what a list of to do
for for this government and and those
employers
yes absolutely and also this is going to
be a unique stress I think that's placed
on the government because you know the
the reason that these uh workers have
been balloted is overpay which of course
is advised on by independent pay bodies
but uh it is the government and
ministers that essentially have to
decide on how that pay is going to go
forward and there is going to be extreme
resistance as we all know because the
fiscal picture in government is
incredibly bad
um which means that it's unlikely that
these workers are going to be given the
pay Rises that they seek I think the
issue here
um as well is that people have really
gotten to the end of their tether on
issues like pay we've gone through
several Cycles uh of sort of wage
freezes in the public sector and whilst
I have a lot of Sympathy for the
government's position in that there is
very little room to maneuver I think it
is quite obvious where the frustration
is coming from with a lot of people who
face stagnating wages for a very long
time in a period where the cost of
living is becoming you know incredibly
unmanageable
yes the fiscal position is indeed
difficult we will find out more about
that next week obviously
um next week today but in terms of of
what happens next and the unions the eye
suggesting they'll meet on Monday to try
to coordinate their members strike
action which could see rail workers walk
out at the same time as National
highways teams possibly more Steve what
I mean what what's the picture look like
from your perspective
very Bleak I mean I I for a book I'm
doing I've been looking at the winter of
discontent recently in 1979 which is
that famous kind of iconic period where
actually quite a lot of the images from
the winter of discontent of 79 were
based on unofficial strikes in just one
part of the country you know the Dead
unburied the rubbish on the streets
um it was not actually as universal or
as bad as mythology suggests if all of
these official strikes balloted strikes
go ahead it will be much much worse than
the winter of discontent in 79
um now who knows whether they or well
but as you suggest some of them are
being coordinated for maximum uh
disruption and
um it's not at all clear what the way
through is here because Asama suggested
the government is if anything determined
to do even less in terms of public
spending and they than they were just
four weeks ago so uh and yet there is
this cost of living crisis and this
intense frustration and these are
balloted strikes and it's a collision
course with no obvious solution at the
moment yes and just on the
um you know the the Autumn uh spending
statement we're expecting next week
um some people The Narrative starting to
be you know this figure of 55 billion is
arbitrary it's sort of chosen to pay
back now and I see in the financial
times that the chancellor they're
reporting is looking at filling about
half of the 55 billion fiscal whole by
freezing public spending in real terms
for three years after 2025 so it does
feel like kicking that can down the road
possibly but in the meantime if we go
Selma to the the times that demand for
pay and for funding quite clear uh with
the worst ever NHS waiting times uh
which the paper says is now costing
lives
yes so uh We've obviously had uh this
month the worst uh waiting times on
record and this is something that the
government has spent a lot of time
trying to say that they are looking to
uh resolve and a lot of this obviously
is Legacy from the pandemic
um but the strikes and what's going to
happen to the public sector spending is
going to compound a lot of this and in
some of the reporting I it's not clear I
can't see whether it's actually in the
times uh but in a lot of the reporting
around this there's obviously the
question about whether
um actually the the NHS is going to have
some form of protection around us in
terms of their spending cuts but even
with that uh and with real terms prices
rising it's going to be a really painful
exercise throughout the winter and
obviously into the new year to be able
to see how those waiting lists are going
to come down and how GP surgeries and
operations and waiting list in more
General really are going to improve
their services and I think people are
really starting to feel the frustration
across the piece and the strikes are
just going to compound this
and meantime The Daily Express
um Steve knowing its audience I guess
with with this story
um the architect of the government
social care cap has launched a scathing
attack on moves to delay its
implementation the idea that you only
spend so much of a proportion for
example of your own home ownership on
your social care costs uh which got
thrown up after the dementia tax issues
of uh of Theresa May
this is a complete shambles if you
remember when uh Boris Johnson uh stood
on the steps of number 10 for the first
time in July 2019. he said he had a plan
for social care I'm not at all sure did
but in the end they put up National
Insurance to pay for a social care Levy
even then it wasn't going to social care
for a time it was going to go to the NHS
now they've scrapped the National
Insurance rise and that's still in place
that's that's the one thing from the
truss era that remains in place so it's
not at all clear where the money uh is
going to come from was going to come
from
um but I think the express has
campaigned not only perhaps with its own
demographic in mind and the fact that
Boris Johnson one of its Heroes authored
this in the first place but because it
is uh an absolute betrayal it was in
their Manifesto in 2019 that they were
going to do this and as I say it was the
one thing that Boris Johnson highlighted
apart from brexit when he got in now
he's not there now now there have been
many prime ministers since but it has
been a theme I'd say based on the
manifesto as well and it looks as if yet
again
the will to address this issue is just
going to crumble and it's going to be
drop yeah a little bit like pension age
uh Rises which got booted out for years
until Tony Blair tackled it certainly
but um just very quickly Salma
reflection on what I read out from the
financial times this idea that half of
the 55 billion fiscal hole will be dealt
with effectively after next election you
know would that be a good solution to
this would it keep the markets calm
enough do you think
I think probably one of the reasons that
they are doing that which is essentially
changing the profile of when they're
paying debt back is that they can't do
it within this electoral cycle because
there isn't enough time left and
changing the profile of being able to
sort of spend it over a longer term
period
um also means that you're spreading the
pain out across a longer period of time
um you know the reality is though
whether the markets respond to that or
not is what the market judgment is going
to be as to what happens at the next
election because there are lots of
points at which this plan can be
appended another budget could change
what the plans are for this one an
election and perhaps a new government
could also change what the plan is going
to be on this fiscal picture so you
might set that out and it might calm the
markets for a certain point but there is
always ways that that can actually be
altered
um coming down the track
and let's just move on um Steve to
Ukraine if we can front page of the
Daily Telegraph uh this big G20 meeting
coming up the suggestion is that
Vladimir Putin could arrive via video
link and uh the U.S uh reportedly uh
telling Ukraine there is a window of
opportunity to start talking to discuss
an end game in this but um you know
that's a very sensitive issue isn't it
allies telling Ukraine what to do as a
sore subject
it is but I hope
um these reports are which made the
Splash in the telegraph uh are true that
there is going to be some attempt some
level of Engagement with who knows what
uh outcome if it were to take place but
I mean the alternative is so Bleak of
just these continuing nightmarish image
which I know you've been featuring again
uh today on the news bulletins and so on
um that at some point there has to be
some kind of diplomatic initiative now I
know the British government position and
many other governments position is
Ukraine must be seen to win without
quite specifying what that means
precisely so I do think it's vaguely
tentatively encouraging that the US is
trying to get some kind of uh talks
going who knows where they will go maybe
they'll go nowhere but it's I think
okay full coverage of that G20 Summit
certainly stay there both of you lots
more still to come um including the
former Chancellor quasi-partain giving
an interview saying he warned Liz trust
her policies were heading too far and
too fast back with that in just a moment
[Music]
watching The Press preview with me now
Steve Richards and Salma Shaw welcome
back to both of you and somewhere we go
straight to the times
um an interview with quasi-quarting
absolutely fascinating about what he
thought about Liz trust was doing and
what he thought about that mini budget
what do we learn
well this is an absolutely astonishing
interview because of course this is
probably the first time that
quasi-quartering the former Chancellor
is spoken in any detail about what
happened with that mini budget and I
think the the headline take away from
this and a lot of the quotes that are
used you know early on in the piece are
all about how he was telling the Prime
Minister that perhaps she should slow
down with her Breakneck speed uh that
she was taking in order to create growth
in the economy and um a one of the
quotes that I find absolutely
astonishing in this piece is that he
says that he he does believe that he
Bears some of the responsibility of the
mini budget which
um of course he does because he's the
chancellor that delivered it and I think
it's very interesting from my
perspective certainly reading this is
that he's slightly distancing himself
from you know what is very clearly a
train wreck of a political intervention
and um sort of pushing it all on Liz and
saying that actually I didn't think it
was a great idea for her to sack me uh
because the Prime Minister was going to
be next
um and there is a lot of sort of
redefining and perhaps putting a little
bit of his own
um historical gloss over events now
um now that he's given this interview I
think perhaps just to save his
reputation a little yes and found out
that he had been sacked after seeing a
tweet from the times his political
editor but after the money budget he
says uh Steve we were going at Breakneck
speed and I said you know we should slow
down slow down she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this he said
he had reservations about the scale of
the planned tax cuts in his mini budget
especially as there were no accompanying
plans to reduce government spending I
mean this is you know it's it just
basically puts almost all the blame on
Liz trust does it not
it does and and who knows I mean I for
sure she was clearly driving this uh you
could tell that from the tone of her
leadership campaign and what she said
from the moment she arrived in number 10
uh but he was her accomplice so to speak
and the other thing which um is omitted
from this explanation is he went on all
the Sunday interview programs or at
least one after his many budgets said
you just wait there are more tax cuts to
come now maybe he was carrying out
instructions from Liz truss but he
seemed a pretty enthusiastic evangelist
for this failed Revolution at the time
but this is what often happens actually
with chancellors I mean he went through
the trauma of being sapped at such
humiliating speed but when John Major
Sac Norman Lamont he came and put his
case very quickly they they want to uh
put what they consider to be a version
which will partially rehabilitate them
it's comfort very quickly but this whole
period has been speeded up politics yeah
a fascinating read and the bits we all
want to know obviously as well uh Salma
shasti of Richards thank you both thank
you